a curfew couldn't keep protesters in
Minneapolis at home fires on the streets
of a city in its fourth night of unrest
and across America solidarity turned
into aggression all triggered by the
death of George Floyd an unarmed black
man who died whilst in police custody
protesters in Atlanta targeted CNN's
headquarters and in Brooklyn police used
force to break up crowds the anger is
still palpable
despite this announcement earlier in the
day has been charged by the hand of a
County Attorney's Office with murder and
with manslaughter
Chapman could face up to 25 years in
prison if convicted of the most serious
charge third-degree murder the evidence
in this case has played out across the
world but it's still hard to watch
Floyd gasping for breath and begging
chavin to get off his neck for eight
minutes a new footage appears to show
other officers kneeling on him president
Trump struck an empathetic tone after
earlier making divisive comments on
Twitter I understand the hurt I
understand the pain people have really
been through a lot the family of George
is entitled to justice and the people of
Minnesota are entitled to live in safety
Floyd's relatives have welcomed
Chapman's arrest but not the charges
this community wants Derek chavin to
face a more serious murder charge they
also want charges for the other officers
involved and until that happens what
we're seeing here is some people are
simply not willing to stay in and obey
orders
the fate of these officers won't just
matter - George Floyd's family many in
America are appalled by the sight of
another black man dying at the hands of
the police often without consequence and
they are demanding justice
Becky Cottrill Sky News Minneapolis